it's by and Larry life for decades
futurists have been predicting that
education would be revolutionized by
computers and the Internet first we
heard lots about putting libraries
online than computers in the classroom
then universities like MIT offering free
courseware but nobody figured on a young
man named Salman Khan his site teaches
math science history and more to
hundreds of thousands worldwide and it's
all free the Khan Academy is most known
for what's now about a thousand videos
on YouTube and starts literally at one
plus one equals two it goes all the way
up to college level calculus and physics
everything isn't these very fort
encapsulate videos one concept of the
time my cousin nadia was visiting me
from New Orleans when I was in Boston
and she was having trouble with masters
in sixth grade at the time I agreed to
do this for both tutoring with her so I
started putting up videos on YouTube and
before I knew at random people all over
the world started watching them and
cutting me letters and testimonials and
I start getting excited about it and I
just kept going
I think I've learned three only about
math in the past three weeks than I had
in all four years of my high school
study when you wash them just comprehend
everything I ended up passing a whole
bunch of tests from this video one thing
that kind of shocked make it a lot of
letters from the Middle East I get a lot
of letters from Latin America GOP agonda
it's really reached far more students
than I could've ever imagined right now
they're about a thousand videos I
started recording about three years ago
now i'm doing it full-time i'm hoping to
be able to put out a couple hundred
videos a year i see a world where
literally anyone with access to a
computer in the internet will be able to
go to the Khan Academy and get a
world-class education impressive right
so let's get to know the man behind this
virtual global classroom joining us live
via Skype from Mountain View California
Khan Academy founder Salman Khan hey
Salman hello from New York thanks for
doing this with us very good to be here
I gather you believe you're a better
teacher on video than in person is that
correct that's what my cousin's first
told me when I put up the the very first
youtube video I viewed it a bit of a
backhanded compliment but I think
they're what they were saying i was
doing these these remote tutoring
sessions these virtual sessions with
them and i think what they liked about
the Youtube version of me as opposed to
the live version of me is that they
didn't have the stress of feeling like
their cousin in boston was judging them
or or you know or that they had to
answer questions immediately or fear
feeling feeling or looking stupid to to
the instructor and if they could watch
and pause and repeat whatever they
wanted to 1,500 videos 14 million views
what's the genesis of this Salman um you
know just like I just said it was it was
it started with me tutoring my cousins
remotely they were New Orleans I was in
Boston and it worked out really well for
them when I had one or two or three that
I was tutoring but they started doing
well so I wanted a tutor or more and
more I had a day job I was an analyst at
a hedge fund at a time and the logistics
got difficult and I thought well at
least would be nice maybe I could scale
myself up a little bit if I made some
YouTube videos and as you just
mentioned their their initial feedback I
thought it would be a nice to have
supplement something that they could use
to review concepts it wouldn't be as
good as our live interactions but the
first feedback I heard from them was
that it was actually better let's let's
see an example of you teaching this in
particular is you teaching of all things
differential equations and what's
interesting here and how this is a
departure from what we've learned before
about just regular equations is let me
write down a regular equation just to
remind you what they look like so a
regular equation if we had one variable
would look something like this I don't
know x squared plus i don't know the
cosine of x is equal to the square root
of x i just made that up here the
solution is a number or sometimes it's a
setup number sometimes there's more than
one right if you have a polynomial you
could have more than one values of x
that satisfy this equation here for a
differential equation the solution is a
function our goal is to figure out what
function of X and here i wrote f of X
explicitly but what function of X
explicitly satisfies this relationship
or this equation so let me show you what
I mean by that and I have my
differential equations book from college
so I'm going to use that as as we go so
haha that high school math feeling there
it is but a little beyond high school
math but I guess how do you how do you
approach I mean you were ok came out of
hedge funds whatever were you an expert
in differential equations I you know an
expert's kind of a loaded word
especially think about things in kind of
academic topics I'm not a cutting-edge
researcher at the at the you know the
leading edge of differential equations i
have not contributed to the field of
differential equations but i am someone
who loved math i was into math and you
know high school college I was a math
major but I teach things outside of my
credential areas as well but but the way
I see it as long as someone has I think
what I bring to the table is being able
to connect the intuition behind a lot of
concepts and be able to communicate you
know
say in a way that I wish it was
delivered to me the first time so that's
really what i'm trying to do and you do
all of these yourself all 1,500 videos
in every subject is you it's all me I
Gioconda I'm the Faculty of the Khan
Academy are their subjects that are
harder for you to do well um you know
it's I like challenging myself because
when I started doing this a lot of
people said okay you've done some
algebra to calculus and what you do
calculus can you do a chemistry in which
you do chemistry can you do the
humanities so I always like pushing the
boundaries and I just naturally like
learning different topics I would say i
wouldn't say harder is the word but i
think it requires more prep on my part
to do something like the French
Revolution than it does to do save the
differential equations videos do you
have a business model you give these
away for free right yeah the decision
was made actually before I even quit my
job to make this amount not-for-profit
entity make sure that that it stays
focused on its goal which is to give
education away for free the way I'm
paying my bills well I was living off of
savings when I put my job in September
of 2009 and until recently I was
essentially just living off of savings
but very recently we've got enough
donations to support a small salary for
me and give us a bit of a runway and and
hopefully we'll get more it's the paid
university concept and old-fashioned
concept as far as you're concerned or is
this just an alternative for a very
select group of people well it's
definitely an alternative I don't think
it's for alternative for a select group
of people i think it's it's you know
when you look at the user base there's
any what people who are gifted students
want to race ahead there's a lot of
college students that all different
skill levels there are home schoolers
using it there are retirees using it so
so i would say it's a selective it's a
fairly broad audience and it's at
minimum that it's at minimum kind of a
nice to have in terms of the college
experience I think there's things
College doing right I think it's nice to
go to a campus that's well manicured and
have a nice experience there but i think
this does challenge some of the notions
of why do we have these 300 person
lectures at some University actually all
universities you have these 300 person
lectures when you can get on demand
instruction at your own
pays or when you want it you know you
don't have to take notes it's always
there for you who are your users
primarily I realize it's a diverse group
but do you find certain kinds of people
certain groups of people are really you
know hitting on your stuff for certain
uses in their lives yeah the core users
who you would expect it's i would say
high school and college students mainly
in the u.s. mainly north american say
about 80% North America twenty percent
rest of world but there's a lot or what
as kind of an online you know sparknotes
or some other reason yeah I think there
are students who are stuck in a math
class either they missed some days they
zoned out for a couple of lectures or
they don't connect with the professor
they have and they use this either as a
supplement or to catch up or or really
is really the primary source of
understanding the concepts I get a lot
of letters for people who you know they
don't use the textbook anymore to learn
the concept they know a few people who
don't show up at lecture anymore but go
ahead that's one core group any others
you know the homeschoolers love it I
didn't think about it at first but it's
kind of an obvious group that would
appreciate this type of thing both for
the students directly and for the
teachers for the parents I've actually
gotten some subgroups are using it for
teacher training which which is I mean
it's it's a compliment and and it is
actually being used in the classroom I
get letters from teachers who are one
assigning the lectures for for homework
instead of reading and some teachers are
showing it in the classroom and then and
then using that as a starting point for
discussion and you're obviously very
organized about how you do this we're
going to show another video a little bit
of you talking about how some of the
math and science videos are organized
sure and then when you think about the
sciences we have physics and the physics
playlist is mainly i call them applied
algebra problems so you might want to
watch physics right around after you
finish algebra there's a there's only a
few videos that require calculus I'll
eventually make a entire playlist on
calculus-based physics most of this is
just algebra based physics so you're
ready to go if you have a good
a solid understanding of algebra and
then the other science is the chemistry
it'd be nice to have chem have algebra
the way pre-algebra is probably enough
for most of it pre-algebra is probably
enough for most of it but algebra if you
have your algebra out of the way then
you're going to have no trouble at all
with the chemistry playlist chemistry
and then biology does deal with a little
bit of of probability and things like
that so it wouldn't hurt but that's
actually that doesn't even require too
much mathematics or at least in
mathematics that I've diagrammed here we
could put biology here I guess the big
takeaway is that algebra is really
important for pretty much anything you
want to do there are some genetics
problems that require some basic level
and and some population genetics
population genetics problems that have
some biology in it and then all the
finance and economics that also I think
it assumes a base level of algebraic
understanding so the things on banking
the things on banking you don't have to
have a super advanced if you just so
that's as I said very organized I guess
that's the same kind of thing that any
university would do as they're figuring
out what's a prerequisite for what right
right know that that's the general idea
and actually this video was made a bike
a byproduct of there's so much content
on the site now that I got a lot of
requests for people from people who just
were kind of lost what do I view after
what and and you know the one area where
I think this diverges from the
University model but the University of
model is very I made that diagram was
kind of class based but I think what's
here it's a lot more granular so you can
kind of go straight to the prerequisite
base prerequisites as opposed to an
entire class are you interested in
trying to get accredited or is that not
a goal it's a long-term goal may be to
have some type of directed accreditation
I mean I can imagine a world we actually
have a software piece where we give
people exercises and things like that
and you know at the end of the day ten
years in the future it might be a lot
more informative to an employer
University as opposed to say you have a
3.9 GPA to actually give someone the
data of all of the work that you've done
but in the short term maybe the next
year too i do see a reality where we can
tell people look if you've understood
all of these concepts you are now ready
to go take the GED and you're likely to
pass it or if you take the s80 because
of the exercise that you done we have
you know this level of confidence that
you will get a at X on the s80 so we can
view the Khan Academy is kind of your
coach and then you get your external
credential from some other source I
didn't see you in any of the videos that
we screened do your students ever see
you at a smart boy or with an overhead
projector or anything like that in these
videos no and you know the form factor
started out of me just just not having a
video camera so uh but but then I got a
lot of feedback that this form factor
actually works for a lot of people even
though you know I probably could get a
video camera and go to whiteboard but
people say that it feels a lot more
intimate it's not the the instructors
face isn't a distraction it's kind of
like they feel like I'm the voice you
know I'm either sitting next to them and
tutoring them or they feel like I'm
actually inside of their brain talking
to them but it's that so I think I'll
just stick with it's actually funny
because I got a letter from people who
imagine me in completely different ways
than I might be and they kind of project
their own impressions on to me which is
which is kind of a neat artifact of this
form factor you said that one of your
goals is to teach the way you always
want it to be taught can you put that
into words yeah you know I think it's um
that I'm finding this out more and more
the more concepts i do that there's a
lot of intuitive connections between a
lot of subjects that I think the
thousand page text books and then you
know to some degree the bureaucracies
that the standards making organizations
they kind of chop them up to a level
that you lose all of the all of the
intuition you lose all of the cross
subject interactions and for me what
made math one made science fun is to
really explore things and see how
different concepts were were connected
and what a formula is actually saying
about the universe and so I think people
who watch the kind of kind of a really
fine like I'm not just throwing formulas
at you I give you an intuition for what
the formulas saying and I also tell you
what a thing about the universe
generally what are its implications and
also how did we get that formula you
know I don't just say memorize it and
apply and I think when you when you
start learning that way one it's a lot
more fun because we all actually do want
to learn about the universe and it
actually builds a really really strong
foundation when you when you learn more
advanced topics which are your most
popular videos introduction to
trigonometry inhaling is probably the
bat or in
reduction to calculus all right those
are probably the two most popular
popular videos why well you know trigga
not well I think most people take those
courses both people are at the same time
kind of intimidated by those courses and
I think when you watch those first two
videos you know the introduction of
calculus is an interesting one because
I've had letters from people who take in
calculus and and who got a's in calculus
and then they watch that video and they
say oh I finally understand what
calculus is about like what what's it
even good for so there's that and I
think introduction trigonometry is just
a huge pain point for a lot of students
and so a lot of them kind of end up on
YouTube looking for help so what's the
future for you is it collaboration with
others like you if there are any others
like you to continue to grow or
something else you know I'm very open to
it and when I started off you know when
I only had one hundred videos I thought
that was the the road I would take that
I would find a team of other people like
me and we would just collectively do it
open to it but I've kind of committed
myself that I enjoy doing it so I've
done fifteen hundred videos you know for
over four years and most of those four
years I was working a day job I've done
about six hundred since I've quit my job
in September so I fairly confident that
I could I could do I can tackle a big
chunk of it but I'm sure other people
will kind of join in but then meant it
with software and then a kind of a
community built around the 200,000
people using the site right now I really
turn it into a virtual school hey Salman
great stuff thanks for coming on great
thank you thank